you're rich eccentric uncle just passed
away and you and your 99 nasty relatives
have been invited to the reading of his
will he wanted to leave all of his money
to you but he knew that if he did your
relatives would pester you forever so he
is banking on the fact that he taught
you everything you need to know about
riddles your uncle left the following
note in his will I have created a puzzle
if all 100 of you answered together you
will share the money evenly however if
you are the first to find the pattern
and solve the problem without going
through all of the legwork you will get
the entire inheritance all to yourself
good luck the lawyer takes you and your
99 relatives to a secret room in the
mansion that contains 100 lockers each
hiding a single word he explains every
relative is assigned a number from 1 to
100 air 1 will open every locker air 2
will then close every second Locker air
3 will change the status of every third
Locker specifically if it's open she'll
close it but if it's closed she'll open
it this pattern will continue until all
100 of you have gone the words in the
lockers that remain open at the end will
help you crack the code for the safe
before cousin Thaddeus can even start
down the line you step forward and tell
the lawyer you know which lockers will
remain open but how the key is realizing
that the number of times a locker is
touched is the same as the number of
factors in the locker number for example
in Locker number six person one will
open it person two will close it person
three will open it and person six will
close it the numbers one two three and
six are the factors of six so when a
locker has an even number of factors it
will remain closed and when it has an
odd number of factors it will remain
open most of the lockers have an even
number of factors which makes sense
because factors naturally pair up in
fact the only lockers that have an odd
number of factors are perfect squares
because those have one factor that when
multiplied by itself equals the number
four Locker nine one will open it three
will close it and nine will open it
three times three equals nine but the
three can only be counted once therefore
every locker that is a perfect square
will remain open you know that these ten
lockers are the solution so you open
them immediately and read the words
inside the code is the first five
lockers touched only twice
you realize that the only lockers
touched twice have to be prime numbers
since each only has two factors 1 and
itself so the code is 2 3 5 7 11 the
lawyer brings you to the safe and you
claim your inheritance to badger
relatives were always too busy being
nasty to each other to pay attention to
your eccentric uncles riddles